it's your ultimate Instagram update
here's how all your favorite stars spent
their Tuesday Jenna Dewan Tatum popped
up on the CW's no tomorrow looking hippy
dippy chic but before the episode is she
teased two fans with her tone to tummy
in this sexy behind-the-scenes shot
about to head into the polls for early
voting for myself why cuz it's my
birthday
meanwhile Katy Perry celebrated her 32nd
birthday by exercising her right to vote
and rock it out to Kanye West
then there's Jessica Simpson who enjoyed
a kid-free night out for charity I will
never ever ever put fashion aside the
mom of two looked glam and this black
jumpsuit at the shoes on a shoe gala
fundraiser in NYC David Beckham on the
other hand was with his kiddos they had
an adorable boys night out to watch some
hockey in LA boys a Boys and Bravo
Liberty Jeff Lewis became a dad the
flipping out star showed off his and
partner gages new addition a little
Monroe Christina Lewis and finally
Pretty Little Liars star Keegan Allen
filmed his a final scene for the show he
an on-screen Love Train belisario shared
emotional posts about the big day
you